you're not gonna believe this folks but
the rich are getting richer and the poor
are getting poorer that's right a new
study came out from the Russell Sage
Foundation and they found out some
pretty interesting stuff let's take a
look between 2003 and 2013 the average
household's net worth adjusted for
inflation dropped by 36% in ten years
from about 87,000 to about 56,000 in the
same time frame the wealthiest 5 percent
of the households increased their net
worth by 14% now we've got a 24 percent
gap right there alone
in New York there are 30 about three
hundred ninety thousand New Yorkers
worth more than a million which means
that one out of every 21 residents of
the city is a millionaire I guess that's
why I left New York I'm not a
millionaire all right now we talk about
income inequality all the time here and
it we know it's getting worse but is
this another one of these issues where
it just keeps getting worse because the
whole system is rigged and we just don't
like this just we don't know how to dig
ourselves out of it well I think for me
I don't know why and I'm nowhere near a
part of being a millionaire or a
billionaire or even a thousand-aire
these days but I do feel like it's
important to say that I don't blame most
of these millionaires for being
millionaires they got into you know good
you know they they found their niche
they made it work a free economy sounds
great and that's not the problem I don't
think that's the problem let people make
their money but now that that's
happening and on the other side of it I
don't even know how related they are in
all the cases but it said like you know
the average income was like 87 thousand
now it's 55 but now the cost of going to
college is more expensive your grocery
baskets gonna be half full with the same
that it would have been five years ago
with a you know full cart of groceries
so that's the thing I don't blame them
but I'm certainly angry yeah well every
time we talk about this I always say I
don't begrudge anyone success I do agree
with you and also to have a million
dollars you could live in Westchester
near and work in New York City and have
a million dollars and really not be
there's a difference between ultra rich
and being upper-middle class being a
millionaire used to mean something you
know nowadays when I'm in New York I
can't even step out of my
without bumping into a dozen other
millionaires it's unconscionable yeah I
want people to you're rich
I want you to stand apart millionaire
pool you can't swing your sable without
getting another millionaire I understand
yeah it's it's I agree it's shocking and
horrifying that there are so many
millionaires when we should really be
talking about billionaires no I mean
you're both is where you're both saying
I don't begrudge people their success
and I don't either but the problem is
that we have a system that is rigged
against poor people to keep the poor
people poor and to keep rich people rich
and they're the ones who are rigging the
system it's not really the millionaire
so because you're a millionaire it may
not even put you in the top it probably
puts you in the top 1% but it doesn't
put you it doesn't put you in the mean a
lot of that might be you own a home that
is worth you know seven hundred thousand
dollars you got four thousand dollars in
the bank which is obviously comfortable
but it's not but it's not Daddy Warbucks
but and that's what so when we've done
this and we've talked about the 1% what
I always try to say is what we really
should be talking about is the point one
percent because the one or the point oh
one percent because these are the people
with really the hundreds of millions if
not the billion right and and I I think
I've just we've heard this topic a lot
we've talked about this topic a lot as a
society and I just had this like urge to
like get out in front of it and say that
because I think people always come back
and go you just don't appreciate people
who work hard that is not what I think
anyone is trying to say yeah so okay so
we're all you weren't way too [ __ ]
hard is my producer at MIT 140 it's good
to know so okay so we talk about that
all the time so I guess the real issues
all right so let's move the the rich
people are okay so let's talk about
those poor people so their income down
ten percent in only ten years is there
so who do we blame okay I get it's a
system but it seems to me I don't know
that the Democrats have been any better
I could said nobody's good no nobody is
good everyone's taking money from
Goldman Sachs Hillary Clinton included
you know she just stepped in by the way
this week
george w bush couldn't do a speech for
250,000 so hillary clinton's doing they
were incredible who's responsible for
paying george w bush two hundred
thousand dollars for a speech i mean
some
we're offered a neighbor what's the
return on that oh I mean I know oh I
can't wait to hear his insights he's
really gonna I mean maybe he'll talk
about the political system scene right
now he really got a lot to say about
that yeah so nobody is that the answer
that both both both of the parties well
I think the question is at what point in
time do people become so squeezed that
they actually go and get grab the
torches and pitchforks because that's
what like Nick Hanauer is a
multi-billion every multi-millionaire
Seattle you know made money in the tech
industry and he's talked about this
he supports raising the minimum wage and
doing more for health care and so on and
so forth because he's concerned like
he's like we need to worry about this
you know the gates you know they're not
there's no way our gated communities are
secure enough I've seen there have you
seen the security guards who work there
they're just hoping that the cost of
pitchforks and torches Rises so I don't
they think that don't they see how this
affects everybody and it can affect
everyone in a positive way a society
that just has the top people in the
bottom people can't stand it's like
they've never heard the phrase a high
tide raises many boats so if you're
taking care of your people your people
will take care of you yeah and that's
why we need a strong middle class which
we did have at one time in this country
and who knows maybe one day we will get
back